we had psychic moments aren't you afraid
that you're gonna pick someone and then
down the road be like wow i did pick the
wrong one
psychological breakdowns you put a ring
on melissa's finger you told melissa you
loved her and wanted to spend the rest
of your life with her
and the biggest baddest bachelor ending
of all time the most shocking ending
in bachelor history this is your the
bachelor greatest seasons ever season
one episode eight recap
grab your glasses
it's time for roses and rose
hi everybody it's me lauren zema
oh everybody we had jason mesnick's
season
of the bachelor on the greatest seasons
ever recap review highlight cliff's
notes show this week
the bachelor the greatest seasons ever
and
i felt i had to go a little dark go a
little mysterious
because jason mesnick's season
was jason messed up becoming the most
hated man in america
yes meznik messed up and it became known
as a mesnick
in the bachelor world that it coins the
expression
the mesnick jason sobs over a balcony
it's what we call the mesnick
iconic moment that has a name it's a
mesnick
if you don't know spoiler alert jason
meznick
infamously proposed to one woman
only to dump her and then propose to his
runner-up and they are still together
and it all happened on the after the
final rose so we're gonna talk about it
all but
keep this in mind on this episode
chris harrison actually dubbed it
the most dramatic finale of all time the
most dramatic and explosive finale
in bachelor history he said it
unequivocally
the most shocking ending he said it
definitively
with the most shocking journey to find
love we'd ever seen he dubbed it thus
and you don't hear him do that very
often you know
he might say it could be the most
dramatic dare i say
most dramatic finales ever or it's one
of
the most dramatic but to actually give
it
the title the most shocking ending give
it the moniker
in the most dramatic and explosive
finale knight it
thusly wild absolutely wild you guys so
we're in for a doozy
and i've brought in uh my new favorite
rose
today the palm by whispering angel it's
not a new rosie
oh that was a ghost
that was a ghost wasn't it we're
starting
jason mesnick's season i'm gonna get
into it you guys but you're gonna see
it's very weird
a ghost just knocked that cap out of my
hand she wants me to drink you want me
to drink
i want me to drink too at least we're on
the same page now in the beginning
jason was this great guy right a single
dad
living in seattle basically the plot
line to tom hanks is
sleepless in seattle this is really fun
and helpful and everybody loves tom
hanks so everybody love
jason so we're starting off on night one
and don't drink every time one of the
women says she's
obsessed with jason i'm coming for you
jason
it's so cute i can't wait to give a big
hug how handsome
should i go change into the wedding
dress that i brought oh my goodness
wow jason's really hot i'm obsessed with
jason i think he's the hottest thing
ever
i want him i love him don't drink every
time chris harrison got ominous this
episode
he's like night one went great jason's
off to a great start
so how did it all go so wrong spiral out
of control
we'll find out after the break we're not
taking a break
chris harrison was taking a break do you
see what i'm saying
it's been a little weird to recap and
review a recap and review show
but we're doing it because 2020 you know
you gotta take what you can get that's
what this year's about
but soon we will get the new
bachelorette
at least two as far as i know
claire and tasha i can't wait oh
we're just gonna do one season of roses
and rose it's just gonna be me in it the
whole time
i'm the only host here we go
but you know while things are getting
dark and scary
and we're having to be wary is it
weary or wary when you're being kind of
trepidatious
is that weary or weary which one's tired
wary so if you're being careful or is it
you're weary i'm feeling weary
somebody's got to look this up yuri is a
feeling or showing tiredness
i hear you christian but i think it's
actually wary is where you're
weary just looking out where you're
cautious no jc i think it's weary
no i'm weary of this conversation
this is weary wary
now we know the jason season is going to
be all about
those final two women molly and melissa
but i do want to have a little fun first
with a woman
named shannon jason you have beautiful
tea so
shannon knows a lot about jason she did
her research i've been looking at your
myspace page
i'm totally not a stalker don't drink
for everything
she knew about jason you just had a
birthday on july 5th
oh jeez i don't even know my birthday
homework
and your younger brother larry is he
dating a shannon you have an older
brother okay
okay and he's he's married and he has a
kid named jackson
and i do like what jason said uh about
everything shannon knew about him
he summarized it best saying and i quote
it's flattering it's weird it makes me
uncomfortable it makes me happy it's
flattering it's weird it makes me
uncomfortable it makes me happy it's
just
different it's different put it in the
vows oh wait no actually put this in the
vows
uh shannon told jason i'm not letting
you let me go you can't i'm not
i'm not letting you let me go i'm not
letting you let me go
you can't yikes did you guys watch sex
in the city
do you remember when carrie was trying
to get aiden back with her
she was like you have to forgive me
you have to forgive me you
you have to forgive me you have to
forgive me you
have to forgive me aiden you have to
forgive me aiden
you have to forgive me you have to
forgive me you
have to forgive me you have to forgive
me you have to forgive me
i hope that you can forgive me you have
to forgive me you have to forgive me
and then and then and then
but then when she wants to go kiss him
she starts crying
and uh picking her nose i'm picking my
ass
she's got this napkin and she's like
i i i
i i'm picking my you know what this
means
i'm picking my nose
i i and then it gets
on her tongue
anyway do you want to make out
so jason rejected the kiss
when i went to kiss jason i feel like he
kind of rejected my kiss
and i certainly don't blame him do you
and he kept telling me that i had napkin
on my face
i don't know if we've ever washed that
blanket and another
unequivocal chris harrison calls that
the
most awkward moment in show history
i think that might be the most awkward
moment in bachelor history
just handing out titles here and there
and everywhere
yeah that that's the one okay what will
clacia's
season be the most dramatic of all time
let me know in the comments below and
there is one other woman we need to
spotlight and
it's not because of what she'd
researched it's because
of what she predicted
yes we have to take a moment for naomi's
hometowns i have a very interesting
family
um so naomi she might deserve another
unequivocal
was this the most insane hometown
ever older maybe we're from the future
and i really should say it's naomi's mom
who does the uh predicting i don't know
if she's some kind of soothsayer
be one with the hula hoop a psychic
a spiritual guide but this you guys is
when
the story of the single dad from seattle
gets a little psychological naomi's mom
tells jason she believes in
reincarnation reincarnation is a big
passionate topic of mine how do you feel
about that like past lifetimes
and i don't think that's that weird i
can get behind a past life i'm not sure
i think our soul dies it
continues to live on in my mind what do
you guys think let me know in the
comments below
and then she tells him they were in the
same soul family
i feel like we're in the same soul
family and i don't really know what that
means
like were they in a family in a past
life that's really interesting
and what is a soul family let me know in
the comments below and then
she says jason was a mom
in a past life he had at least one
lifetime as
a mom did you think that was too much
let me know in the comments below
honestly truly deep into my souly
i could put up with any of that what
took it over the edge for me
was the bird murder and i'm not joking
[Laughter]
and all of a sudden i see something
white fluttering towards me and the
first thought i think of is dove
things take a criminal turn they get
weird
now we're in the land of unsolved
mysteries feathers going everywhere i'm
like oh you killed a dub
this home in this hometown contains
a recently deceased bird right now it's
in the refrigerator
so naomi's mom starts telling the story
about how she maybe or maybe not hit a
bird with her car
and all of a sudden i see something
white fluttering towards me and dove and
it's crashed right into the
and they're like did you kill the bird
you killed it up she's like
no no the bird took its own life
no we can't no we killed itself what
and is the bird going to be reincarnated
does she think the spirit of the bird is
in jason
why are we talking about the bird please
god kill me now
she still has the carcass of the dove in
her refrigerator
and we learned that because a small
child ran out carrying it
you told me
yes a tiny young boy ran
forth into the yard with a dead bird in
a
bag oh i feel intense it was weird
it smells a little like chicken and then
naomi's mom wants to bury it yes we're
about to have
a burial for a dove at this point i
wondered if she was covering up some
kind of crime she had her family help
her conceal
the bird body they buried it in the yard
and asked jason to give the eulogy
we thought that jason you might have the
honors of helping us bury it and saying
the eulogy for rosie
please god kill me now jason sent naomi
home
after that sorry deborah
it's getting weird
i don't know how else to ask this what
did you guys think of the bird suicide
let me know in the comments below i
don't know you guys it was so i'm not
trying to like judge
be spiritual be one with the earth i
just didn't know why this
woman um was keeping the bird body in
her refrigerator
if you killed it just bury it that day i
think you know
certainly doesn't feel sanitary alrighty
then
alrighty then
so that's the first sign of something
afoot our soothsayer bird murderer lady
but we've got to get down to the nitty
gritty so then we see jillian and
jason's love story honestly it was
beautiful they were into each other but
ultimately it didn't work out so i just
kind of want to fast forward
because jillian would ultimately end up
being the bachelorette and also we're
gonna catch up with her today and here
she is
it's been a long time and interestingly
we did ask jillian about claire you're
about to
add another sister to the group and that
is claire but jillian says she thinks
that bachelorette claire
will be incredible and mature claire is
gonna be
incredible i think that she is beautiful
i think she's smart i think she's well
spoken i think she's mature
what is gonna happen what do you guys
think happened with claire let me know
in the comments below okay
anyway yeah i only wanted to talk about
jillian so we can talk about claire
i'm just being honest you know we want
to talk about what we want to talk about
we've been through enough this year
we're ready for our new season so now we
get to
the really intense relationships jason
and molly and melissa eminem
but not the chocolate kind i wish i had
an m m right now i love them and
specifically peanut m ms they're really
the best you get like salty
and sweet and you get kind of like a
good crunch and they're also quite
filling my absolute favorite candy
what's your favorite candy
if peanut m ms would like to send me
some
so m number one melissa fell in love
with jason i have
absolutely fallen in love with you
and m number two molly fell in love with
jason
i really think i'm falling in love with
you molly even dubbed him
the love of her life
the love of my life oh my gosh really
and again it's really
[Music]
where i grew up um it was kind of in the
woods and we didn't really have
neighbors and you know we would get kind
of scared at night it was pretty dark
and my mom um instead of trying to
comfort us
would just go
and like try to scare us more that's why
i became funny
i had to try to protect my psyche so
molly dubs him
the love of her life the love of my life
and spoiler alert
what we know is that jason would end up
proposing to melissa dumping melissa and
then returning to molly in the air
together now
so she was right psychic predictions
suits saying knowing the future
because then she gets even more psychic
over dinner
she asks jason if he's at all worried he
might pick
the wrong person aren't you afraid that
you're gonna pick someone and then
down the road be like wow i did pick the
wrong one
i should have picked that other person i
don't know what molly's doing for a
living now
but i think start one of those psychic
hotlines you know
uh like miss cleo back in the day get
that going molly
open up a practice the future's
uncertain people want to know
they need some security and they want to
know what's going to happen and i think
you have that gift
so we're at the proposals and jason is
looking at molly but he's also looking
like he's going to throw up
it's all so obvious before you say
anything
and it's happening and the dumping of
molly is rather savage
if you ask me what did you think of the
way that jason
broke up with molly he tells her you
have
me every time you look at me with those
eyes
you have me but i gotta let you go i
don't know how i could ever
let you go but i have to what
molly's confused and she's the psychic
where's naomi's mom when we need her
were you confused at this point i was
like hey nice single dad
i hate you now that's good you'll have a
lot to tell oprah but once again
our clairvoyant molly says
you've made a mistake i just think
you're making a huge mistake and she's
correct
i don't know what's happening with jason
his face was so
unreadable to me as he was putting molly
into the limo
what did you think was going through
jason's mind at that point because
he kind of looked like again he was
gonna barf
or burst or or break down
oh and then he did yes jason returns
inside
and he just gut punches himself with
that balcony
and he is crying and he
is mesmeking
if only we'd known then what it would
become now
the mesnick but he couldn't he didn't
know what he really wanted and so he
proposed to melissa
but now things are really getting scary
the wind is whipping through the air
the lightning and thunder are echoing
across the plains
there's a dark figure heading towards us
the lights are dimming the after the
final rose
is happening have a seat
so it's the after the final rose but
what's interesting here
we don't have an audience
no i actually asked chris harrison about
this
why didn't we have an audience for
jason's after the final rose when
the producers must have known he
intended to break up with his beyonce
melissa
and try to get back with his runner-up
molly
and he said you know they just made the
decision uh to be like sensitive and to
make it more dramatic and so
here we are no audience what did you
guys think of it it was kind of weird i
sort of wanted the reactions
very 2020 no crowd you know pipe in some
reaction noise
like add in a couple reaction faces it's
been a crazy time
things have been different we're not
right for each other
jason basically tells chris harrison you
know
i'm not feeling it with melissa anymore
the chemistry has been completely
different
we tried i'm doing all i can
to make this work with melissa but i
can't control how i'm feeling
we were hanging out in new zealand i
mean we spent some time afterwards in
new zealand together
it is not working for me i've tried but
i can't
okay and when he tells melissa this she
says
so things get hard and you're not even
trying the second
you start having doubts it's i'm just
gonna pull away whoa things are
different and i don't even want to try
and i agreed with melissa what did you
think i mean jason's throwing all this
at her on tv she apparently had no
idea he was going to break up with her
and tell her that he had feelings for
molly what did i do
you didn't do anything no something
happened so we've had our psychic
moments
and now we're going to have our
psychological breakdowns
and by that i mean melissa starts
referring to herself
in the third person because she chose
melissa she's like so did you even try
with melissa
were you even doing your best with
melissa but you don't want to fight for
melissa
did you even have feelings for melissa
you put a ring on melissa's finger
did you really love melissa you told
melissa you loved her so now you're just
gonna do this to melissa
but you don't wanna fight to see if that
can work now you're just gonna throw
melissa away
it's like melissa you are you
now molly's gonna come out and jason is
telling molly he loves her
i haven't been able to stop thinking
about you and this time
i was confused by molly's face
i don't know if she was just processing
this information but she wasn't really
having an emotional reaction
she's like what
i'm confused i mean i'm very
confused
we can see where things go you know i
think we can
see where things go if you were molly
what would you have done with this
information from jason let me know in
the comments below
she does say her feelings didn't go away
my feelings never
went away and then she gives kind of a
that's all i'm asking oh but now things
are escalating quickly she's smiling
and they're kissing and jason tells her
that he will
never stop loving her forever i am
falling in love with you still
and it will never stop felt like you
should have been a little more gun shy
with that phrasing if i'm being honest
i mean you just broke up with your
fiance for another woman
and now you're like it's forever and it
will never stop
but you know what forget me because
things are really escalating
now oh
should we answer can you see who this is
hi chris harrison
hi i'm filming roses and rose what are
you working on
uh the bachelorette all right okay bye
[Music]
but forget what i'm saying because get
cut to the wedding
from the moment that i met you you gave
me butterflies
yes the two of them got married on tv
back when the bachelor franchise still
did
televised weddings and you know i guess
i should just shut up with any criticism
of
what jason did or what he had to say or
how he did it
because they are married and they're
happy
i mean it's raining the sky is crying
the music is swelling
the romance is in the air and i miss
weddings so many weddings were put on
hold this year
in bachelor nation alone we were
supposed to go to three weddings this
year
jojo and jordan kevin and astrid and
raven and adam
and i was excited to attend them all
do you miss weddings i want to be in the
presence of you know the toasts and the
dancing and
the cake especially
ultimately what did you think of jason
mesnick's season of
the bachelor it was unprecedented at its
time
though not for molly because she
predicted it i just
think you're making a huge mistake and
even though we can't predict what will
happen with the highly anticipated
upcoming season of the bachelorette
we do know what we're getting next week
on the greatest seasons ever
nick viall nobody could have predicted
that nick
was going to be the bachelor after two
seasons on the bachelorette and a season
on bachelor in paradise
i'm on cameo tick tock instagram and
twitter and i love you all so much
thank you for watching roses and rose
[Music]
bye
you